-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
I'm here with Cardi B!
Now, Cardi,
we always do something fun
when you're on the show.
So with that in mind, it's time
for "The Mimic Challenge."
-♪ Mimic Challenge ♪
♪ Mimic, Mimic Challenge, yeah ♪
-[ Chuckles ]
-[ Quietly ]
Now here's how it works.
We each have a bunch of items
to make noise with.
We'll take turns
making a sound with an object,
and the other person has to
immediately match that sound
as precisely as they can.
-[ Whispering ]
Are we doing it this part?
-Oh, no. I don't know
why I was whispering.
Anyway, it's a lot of fun.
Are you ready to do this?
-Sure.
-Alright, since you're my guest,
I will make the first noise
for you to mimic.
-Okay.
-Cardi, make this sound.
[ Pen clicks ]
-Click, click, click, click.
Click, click,
click, click, click.
Click, click, click,
click, click.
[ Ding! ]
Click, click, click, click.
-I like that one.
Alright, now it is my turn.
Click, click, click, click,
click.
Whenever you're ready.
-Okay, you ready?
-Okay, I think so, yep.
[ Keys jingling ]
Do it again.
Sorry, here we --
Ding-a-ling a-ling a-ling
a-ling a-ling a-ling!
[ Ding! ]
Alright.
-I mean, you sounded like
a old phone, but okay.
-Old Phone was my rap name
back in the day.
-Oh, Lord.
-Yo, give it up for Old Phone!
I come out.
-Whoo!
[ Air horn blares ]
-Alright, here we go, ready?
Alright. Make this sound.
[ Crunching ]
-[ Chomping ]
[ Ding! ]
-That's fantastic, alright.
-I did good?
-That was fantastic.
Actually, you sounded
just like it.
-Yeah.
But can you do this?
[ Low squeaking ]
-Oh, yeah. Wow.
Alright. Alright, hold on, now.
Wow. [ Laughs ]
Like, sounds --
Reminds me of prom night.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Let me --
[ Honking ]
[ Ding! ]
-That's pretty good.
That's pretty --
Actually, that was the best one
you have done,
so you nasty.
-It was?
-Yeah, you're really nasty.
-Okay, here,
I got this one here.
[ Cranking ]
-I'm not -- I'm not liking
how you guys are giving me
the hard ones to mimic.
And I feel like
you guys are cheating.
-I disagree. Completely.
-And I don't feel like
a welcome guest.
[ Laughter, groaning ]
-I feel like this should
make more of a noise.
I kind of agree with you here.
They'll get better.
I have other ones.
-May -- No, may I please
hear the sound again?
-Ready?
[ Cranking ]
-[ Crunching ]
Yeah, this is hard.
-Whatever.
Okay.
So, let's see this.
[ High-pitched honk ]
Oh, my -- I didn't know it's --
I didn't know
it would blow so hard.
This is so little.
-Goodness Lord.
-But the little things
be the mightiest.
[ Laughter ]
-Again, it's reminding me
of prom night.
Here we go.
Let me hear --
So, do it one more time.
It's like --
-Okay, okay. Goes like this.
[ High-pitched screech ]
Oh!
-Alright.
[ Screams ]
-That sounded like me
when I gave birth, but okay.
[ Ding! ]
Okay.
-Okay, ready?
-Yeah.
-How about this?
Okay, ready?
-What the hell is that?
Oh.
-Champagne Bardi.
-Champagne --
[ Laughs ]
[ Cork pops ]
Ooh. That sounded good.
That's such --
That's such a sexy sound.
Okay. Okay, ready?
Pooh. Wait.
Boo! Pooh. Boo!
-Pooh. Pooh.
-Boo! Boo!
-[ Popping lips ]
-Boo!
Pooh.
I can't --
[ Ding! ]
-We combined
to make that one. Okay.
You're up.
-Okay.
Okay.
[ Whistle blows ]
This the Titanic whistle.
[ Laughter ]
-Titanic whistle?
Wait. When they saw the iceberg,
that's what they did?
-When -- When she was trying
to find a rescue boat
after she let Jack go, trifling.
She started going like --
[ Whistle blowing ]
-[ Laughing ]
-Y'all remember that part?
-I never saw the end.
Don't tell me how it ends!
So far, it's a fun cruise.
[ Laughter ]
So --
[ Blowing, trilling tongue ]
I can't.
-Jimmy, I know
you know how to whistle!
-[ Whistling ]
-That one is better.
That one is better, yeah.
-That's better?
See, I just needed
some coaching, that's all.
Alright, ready for this?
-Well, you know I could blow.
-Ready for this one?
-[ Laughs ]
[ Off-key honking ]
-Aw.
You know what?
I could do that sound better
if air was coming out
of my butt.
But --
[ Laughter ]
-You know what?
Maybe I'll use --
Sorry, I was --
[ Mouthpiece clatters ]
Whoa!
I'll send it back to you.
[ Both laugh ]
-But let me try to mimic it.
-Alright, ready?
-[ Whirring ]
[ Ding! ]
I got my last one.
This my last one.
-Okay. I got this.
It's for the win.
[ Strained shrieking ]
[ Shrieking ]
[ Ding! ]
-Yeah.
[ Low screeching ]
-[ Gasping, shrieking ]
[ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
-Alright. Thank you so much
for playing.
That was --
Thank you so much to Cardi B.
Her new single "Up" is out now!
-Whoo!
-Episodes of "Cardi Tries"
are available on Facebook Watch.